well welcome back to p on sens I'm
joined Now by one of the guests at this
evening's Big White House Party
celebrating Jewish anuka it's the author
and first special Envoy for combating
anti-Semitism Noah Tish Noah thank you
very much indeed for joining me um let
me start by asking you your reaction to
this extraordinary situation in America
where the heads of three of the most
preeminent universities were basically
rendered incapable in public of saying
that the genocide of Jews were
constitute any kind of
harassment yeah but what we're seeing
right now in America is the entire house
of cards falling down and exposing this
deep seeed anti-Semitism that has rooted
very deeply in Academia not just in
terms of the students but also in terms
of Faculty I think that these uh
presidents have failed miserably it
would have been the easiest answer to
say yeah sure you can be a Nazi and you
can say and call for a genocide of any
ethnicity but know it's unacceptable and
I think what we were pointing out to is
that culturally it is unacceptable would
have been unacceptable to call for a
genocide of any other marginalized
minority and rightfully so but when it
comes to the Jewish people it seems to
be okay and that needs to stop I am very
much against censorship against cancel
culture against Dei against anything
that is trying to put barriers on Free
Speech however I'm also all for equal
opportunities and right now the Jews are
not included in any of these
conversations and we need to remember
this we are the smallest minity and the
highest rate of targeted attacks um in
America right now so you know people
forget that the Jewish Community is
0.18% of the world population there are
not a lot of Jews and you know we need
to be treated equally clearly there is a
lot of uh divided opinion about the
Israel government's response to what
happened on October the 7th and people
are perfectly entitled to have a lot of
uh very passionate views about that I I
have some myself um but it seems to me
there's a conflation between what the
Israeli government is doing and the way
that people are reacting personally to
Jewish people uh and that's that's a
dangerous
conflation yes it is and we've been
saying this for a very long time
anti-zionism so this Obsession and
hatred toward Israel is just
anti-Semitism anti-Semitism is a
shape-shifting conspiracy theory it
changes throughout the generations and
right now it shifted into this
anti-zionism that we say that we see so
you basically take out the word Jew and
replace it with Zionist or Israel and
anything goes it's a very dangerous uh
thing that's happening right now and we
see this every time something flares up
in Israel people are attacking Jews all
over the world this is nothing short of
anti-Semitism this is as old as time and
we have to remember that obviously I'm
going to State the obvious here the
Jewish Community around the world is not
responsible for the actions of the
Israeli government but any other country
would have reacted very very forcefully
to the atrocities that have occurred on
October 7th and if anybody else has
another solution on how we need to deal
with Kamas I'm very excited to hear what
they have in mind but this is It's the
hardest it's the toughest Gaza is the
toughest Battleground in the world right
now and what Hamas did what Iran did is
basically sacrific Gaza and sacrific the
people of Gaza so the IDF in Israel is
doing the best that we can to have as
little amount of casualties as possible
but you know very well that this is
hamas's objective to have as many
casualties as we possibly can exactly
because they want Israel to be in the
center stage and be called out on and uh
this is what's happening and we need to
resist that we need to resist that with
every Power you know every fiber of our
being and remember there's 139 civilians
that are still in the hands of Kamas
still women and still young adults and
two babies that they don't even they say
that they don't know where they are we
know what is happening there and we know
that the West is next if anything
happens to Israel the the West is coming
next and we need to stop that fight
against it you're an actress we we've
seen after things like the murder of
George Floyd and the black lives matter
movement there was barely a star in
Hollywood who didn't want to uh lassu
their hat to that campaign and to be
seen to be uh taking part in it and to
be an active participant in it and to
supporting uh the African-American
community in particular but I've been
struck by the very limited number of
Hollywood stars prepared to put their
heads over the parit about what has been
happening since October the 7th I mean
are you surprised that more of your
colleagues in the industry are not
speaking
out sadly I'm not surprised at all and
um to be honest I'm seeing a better
respond this time around than I did
throughout the years Israel and the
Jewish people are not a cool cause to
stand behind but I'll tell you what's
even more heartbreaking what's
heartbreaking for me is various chapters
of BLM supporting the Kamas terrorist
attack there is no resistance that
includes raping women and beheading
children and burning families alive
there isn't and what we say basically
one of the things that broke our hearts
the most was what we call the atrocities
of October 7th and then the atrocities
of October 8th because on October 8th
before Israel did anything in Gaza any
retaliation we saw Act activists and
social justice Warriors in America
aligning themselves with a terrorist
organization not understanding the
region at all when I saw the BLM Chicago
chapter posting that paraglider relating
to that murderer as some sort of a
freedom fighter it's a such a misguided
issue and the West is making a terrible
mistake a terrible mistake you had a
guest on your show you try to get him to
say whether or not they want Sharia law
in the west that that is the truth that
is exactly what we're dealing with this
Jihadi culture that Israel is fighting
against is not just against Israel it's
against the entire Western culture and
civilization and everything that we hold
near dear and we need to remember that
Israel is fighting the West's War not
just their own War Benjamin Netanyahu
the prime minister's come under a lot of
criticism from within in Israel all the
polls vary against him and increasingly
so um but because of his apparent
knowledge of uh the the financial
support that Hamas were getting uh and
you yourself were quite critical
actually before October the 7th about
his attempts to usurp the power of the
Supreme Court which many people in
Israel certainly were as they took to
the streets in big numbers um do you
think that out of all this when it's all
over and hopefully that comes sooner
rather than later do you think that
neton Yahoo uh will be able to continue
as prime
minister we don't know that the fact of
the matter is there is a war that we
need to win right now and we call it in
Israel at 6:00 after the war this is
when we're going to deal with politics
right now the entire country is United
behind the military and behind the
government which is a Unity government
in order to solve this I think one of
the things that have happened in Israel
is that the conception of Hamas um as a
body that is intended to rule Gaza
collapsed so we all thought that if they
only can help their people they might
not want to kill the Jews and Slaughter
Israel and wipe Israel off the map and
we were all wrong one of the things that
we understood is that Hamas we need to
listen them for the first the first time
when they call in their chapter to
eliminate Israel and to slaughter the
Jews that is what they want and they
were pretending for a very long time to
want um more work permits in Israel and
to negotiate with Israel and to have
conversations and the meantime took all
that money from Qatar with the approval
of the Israeli government which was
wrong and instead of of building a
future for their people they build
territ tunnels 500 kilometers long
underneath Gaza there's literally a town
underneath Gaza of Terror tunnels all
that money that should have gone to the
gazan people had gone to Hamas we're
starting to hear voices from Gaza that
are complaining finally about Hamas
because they are the ones that need to
be liberated so free Gaza indeed free
Gaza from Kamas not from Israel no disp
thank you very much and for joining me
ie shouldn't can I you may I use this
opportunity to say one more thing sure
yeah so I want to use this opportunity
because I know you have a lot of viewers
in the Arab world so I would like to use
this opportunity to speak to the Arab
world and to speak to the moderate Arab
countries and citizens and you know who
you are okay this Israeli Palestinian
conflict the Arab Israeli conflict has
been perpetuated and held and and flamed
by a bunch of other countries in the
region this was comfortable convenient
for them to keep it kind of going
there are there's a lot of stakes in the
Arab world to solve this right now and
in order to stabilize the region again
we will need the moderate Arab countries
and the moderate people the Arab people
in the region to speak up and start
doing what needs to be done this cannot
be solved just with Israel and just with
the Palestinian people there are a lot
of other countries that have stakes in
this and I'm begging them to actually do
this what Hamas wanted to do and what
Hamas effectively did is destabilize the
entire Middle East and I know that the
majority of the normal people in the
Middle East don't want that they don't
want jihadism and they don't want this
extremism and it's time that we actually
start reimagining what the Middle East
is going to be like and the day after
Hamas is gone no tshp thank you very
much indeed I appreciate it thank you
for having
me